vous avez carte blanche maison expert en
relations internationales
bonsoir roses blanches maison avec le
recul de ces quatre jours de cessez le
feu
quelles forces en présences tire le plus
de profit politique cessez le feu qui
s'est mis en place vendredi matin marque
d'abord la fin de ce que antonio goûter
riès le secrétaire général de l'onu
avait qualifié d' enfer sur la terre
pour les enfants de gaza cela dit le sur
le plan politique le groupe qui en tire
le principal profit est sans doute le
hamas puisqu'il s'est posé depuis le
début de cette crise comme le principal
défenseur de la mosquée al aqsa qui est
le troisième lieu saint de l'islam comme
vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure dans
votre sujet et puis il a marginalisé
mahmoud abbas et le fatah qui dans le
fond à ramallah n'ont pas pu faire grand
chose
cela dit le fatah et monsieur mahmoud al
mahmoud abbas on prend quelque sorte
prendre leur revanche
cette semaine puisque anthony blinken va
leur rendre visite et qu anthony blinken
ne peut pas rendre visite aux
terroristes entre guillemets du hamas là
le deuxième bénéficiaire de cette crise
c'est probablement le monsieur netanyahu
lui même personnellement puisque
vis-à-vis ses électeurs il est apparu
comme l'homme fort d'israël qui est
capable de défendre israël contre les
terroristes jour votre guillemets et qui
finalement se montre suffisamment fort
et qui par conséquent doit rester à la
tête d'un gouvernement israélien
or comme vous savez il était incapable
de former un nouveau gouvernement et
l'opposition est dans le même état
donc soit il trouvera une formule qui
sera probablement avec les gens de
l'extrême droite israélienne
soit il faudra retourner à de nouvelles
élections
le troisième bénéficiaire c'est sans
doute
le président égyptien si si qui a joué
un rôle déterminant dans la médiation
pour aboutir à ce cessez le feu puisque
lui a des rapports très anciens avec
israël on se souvient que l'egypte a
négocié sont ses rapports avec israël il
ya très longtemps mais il parle aussi
ils continuent ils à des rapports avec
le hamas donc avec les deux côtés c'est
également le cas de la jordanie qui a
normalisé ses relations avec israël un
peu plus tard mais il ya quand même pas
mal de pas mal d'années et qui a
toujours des relations avec le hamas
ce qui n'est pas le cas des pays arabes
qui ont été poussés par donald trump
leur désaccord d'abraham à normaliser
leurs relations avec israël mais il y
avait une petite condition un codicille
pas de rapport avec le hamas
peut-être peut-on dire aussi que à bien
moindre degré l'un des bénéficiaires
indirects seraient le président abdou
gagnent puisqu'il s'étend à nouveau
posée comme le défenseur de l'islam dans
le monde contre contre israël les ceux
qui ont finalement sont peut-être les
perdants c'est d'abord à mon avis joe
biden qui dans le fond pour sa première
crise diplomatique a éprouvé beaucoup de
difficultés le président netanyahu a
résisté à cinq coups de fil du président
des états unis la principale puissance
du monde
le principal allié et bien sans effet et
finalement le président de baden envoie
son secrétaire d'état
anthony blinken pour discuter avec
israël et l'assuré de son soutien
je crois que parmi les autres victimes
de 2,7 et on court on pourrait dire
aussi qu'il y à l'union européenne dans
la mesure où l'union européenne continue
ses divisions n'a pas pu faire grand
chose qu'elle a attendu avant de prendre
clairement position
elle avait implicitement accepter le
report des élections qui avaient décidé
mahmoud abbas parce qu'il craignait une
victoire du hamas et
dans le fond elle n'était pas en
position d'exercer quelques médiation
que ce soit aujourd'hui elle va être
convoqué bien sûr comme toujours pour la
reconstruction de la bande de gaza merci
claude blanchemaison pour ses
explications et reggae